i've always wondered when someone
like you since you were 13 or 14 years
old
you have been kind of catered to and
everybody telling you how wonderful you
are and how great you are
and getting into high school with the
same thing what
is it like now coming to this level
with the level of expectations you had
it's probably even higher than it was at
clemson
yeah for me i've kind of dealt with that
for a few years so it's not
just not changing anything just
continuing to be who i am
and bringing that into a new place i've
learned so many great things at clemson
been surrounded by great people like
coach sweeney and
the whole staff and my teammates and
actually going to bring a teammate with
me travis so
yeah um just being the same person i've
i've been
through the years and not changing just
because you know now i'm in the nfl or
whatever at a new place and
i think just continuing to be me is the
main thing does pressure bother you
no i'm used to it you know that's that's
really what i'm accustomed to now
and i think that's what i operate the
best is under pressure
you know what my dad if he were still
with us would say in response to that
clip peter
i know exactly what he was today you cut
your hair
hand if you got to run your hand through
your hair three times while talking to
one of your elders for 45 seconds it's
time to go to the barber
peter i once got sent back i once got
sent
back to the barber by my dad because
when i came home
my hair wasn't nearly short enough i had
to go back to the barber and say can you
take some more off please
mike i'll just say this his hair is real
and it's spectacular
[Laughter]
but but i'll also make this point this
was one of the cutest things
i've seen in a while trevor lawrence
gets
out of his vehicle shad khan the owner
of the jacksonville jaguars opens the
door
to his car in the back you know the back
door and out comes marissa
is his wife and now here comes trevor
lawrence
and he goes welcome to jacksonville and
all of a sudden
there's a bunch of third-graders who
come with signs to welcome
trevor lawrence and he trevor lawrence
goes hey how you doing y'all and he fist
bumps all of them and everything
and one of the first questions he gets
from one of these kids is
is your hair real so
you know i mean that was his welcome to
jacksonville moment it was it was really
quite cute
but i'll say this mike what i found
really interesting about their draft as
a
whole is that this is a draft that to me
when you take travis etn number two and
you know it sounds like that urban meyer
if he didn't get uh travis etn or
that he would not have taken etn if
qadarius tony was on the board at number
25
but the giants trumped him basically by
taking cadarius tony
uh number 20 overall so he gets travis
etn
who is going to be the kind of guy out
of the backfield that
they hope will be a percy harvin type
not an
every down player but a guy who's going
to be able to be that change of pace guy
and what i also found interesting is
that they still have a hole at wide
receiver they wanted to get a receiver
higher
they wanted to get a tight end higher i
really like luke farrell i've watched a
lot of
justin fields late in the year but and i
think luke farrell will be a better
offensive player than the jaguars think
but be that as it may
i think they wanted this draft to be
we want to help trevor lawrence and the
best way we can help him is either with
a game breaking wide receiver
or his good friend travis etm i really
like that pick for jacksonville
i i was uh surprised first of all i do
have to say this
before i forget uh trevor lawrence's dog
looks exactly like our dog macy
exactly like they could be from the same
letter that's how much they look alike
uh that was an important point that i
had been waiting to make
secondly you mentioned the qadarius tony
situation
i was surprised that urban meyer came
out and said
he really wanted tony at 25. and
you know the the message to travis atn
is you were yeah
sorry pal you are a second choice i
really wanted this other guy that i
didn't get that just doesn't happen and
maybe it's urban meyer
kind of feeling his way through how the
nfl works but most coaches would not say
something like that
that's why i really like urban meyer
right now honestly mike
because like he said to me remember he
said to me a month ago
uh yeah that's the direction we're going
or we're leaning or whatever when i
asked him
why don't you just make it official and
say you're taking trevor lawrence or
whatever
i said is there any doubt you're taking
trevor lawrence
and he gave me that little smirk and
said you know not really
you know but i like the fact that
someone will say
for instance you know was there anything
that surprised you or disappointed you
yeah you know we kind of hope that that
cadarius tony would
come down to us and look i don't think
it's impossible
i i'll tell you this i think it's
possible
that if travis etn were still on the
board
that buffalo might have taken him you
know late in the round
but it's not impossible that he would
have been there high in the second round
for jacksonville so i guess what i'm
saying mike is
i don't think that would have precluded
them from getting travis etn
or some other running back i mean it is
nice that they can reunite trevor
lawrence and travis atn
immediately when they come to the nfl
but there are plenty of other
running backs that are out there in
every round of the draft and that's the
philosophical question that
the steelers and the jaguars resolved at
least for this year
in back-to-back fashion it picks number
24 and number 25 respectively
taking a running back in one round
people have some strong feelings about
that when you can get a james robinson
who's also on the depth chart in
jacksonville
who was undrafted you can get an alvin
kamara in round three a derek henry in
round two
and i'm a firm believer peter if you're
gonna use a first round pick on a
running back
you better have a plan to have them on
the field more often than part of the
time
otherwise take someone else who is going
to be on the field
all of the time and get your part-time
running back later
no i i would disagree on that and i'm
not a big fan of taking running backs in
the first round
as a rule but i think
in this particular case you know when
you look at the offense that they're
going to have
all right what are they really missing i
mean to me
they got marvin jones in free agency and
i really like that he's a little bit
of a of an explosive type guy
in big downfield throws they didn't have
anybody in the backfield or or a tight
end or in the intermediate area of the
field
who could really be a game wrecker and
so i think even if travis etn plays
30 snaps a game i think they could
really be 30 impact snaps if
he's used the way he should be used
which is as your swiss army knife
explosive guy you're gonna you're gonna
split him out some
and you're gonna have him in the slot
some and he's just gonna be a regular
running back
i you know i i it's hard but i think
jacksonville was in position with four
picks
high in this draft to take a guy
like travis etn now if they had one pick
in every round and they have a middle
round pick you know in every round and
they have like
one pick in the top 50 and he's the 20th
pick overall
then i'm not in favor really of taking a
gadget guy
but they had the luxury right now
because they have so many pics
of taking a guy like that who you can
pair with james robinson
and have a great combination in the
backfield the jaguars right now
nationally are kind of a tough team to
get a read on because
they weren't much of the pre-draft
conversation given that
everyone knew they were going to trick
trevor lawrence we were talking about
the 49ers talking about the falcons
talking about every team but the jaguars
because
there was nothing to talk about and they
were 1 in 15 last year
what's your what's your guess as to
what it's going to take for them how
many wins
for us to say okay this team's on the
right track
they'll win five or six games this year
they have the talent now to win five or
six
games they have a quarterback who in my
opinion even if he has
a 1998 peyton manning year where he
throws
28 interceptions or whatever it was 24
you know even if he has that kind of
year he's gonna grow
i just look last year mike two of the
top three quarterbacks picked
they were both on their way to gigantic
seasons
and obviously justin herbert had one joe
burrow
would have had one and will be great in
my opinion i don't say that lightly
i believe joe burrows going to be a
great quarterback in the nfl
and so there's no reason why
trevor lawrence doesn't come in and
when two or three games that nobody sees
him
nobody sees coming beating indy let's
say or beating tennessee in nashville
they're gonna do some things that will
surprise people and
one of the reasons why i think people
don't really understand the jaguars now
joe cullen the new defensive coordinator
no one
really knows joe cullen right now you
know
comes from baltimore where he was a
really great
defensive line some yeah some yeah i
understand that
but also what are they going to be on
offense exactly
look at brian schottenheimer right now
and
everybody looks at brian schotneir and
say em man you know
but brian schottenheimer and daryl
beville on offense to me
are two guys that that are going to be
great to
introduce trevor lawrence to
nf to an nfl offense and are going to be
able to tell him
some really good shortcuts that he's
gonna need to know
so you got veteran coaches uh on both
sides of the ball and i think urban
meyer is basically gonna say
i hired you guys to coach take the reins
the schedule this year consists of all
four teams from the nfc
west all four teams from the afc
east the extra game is a visit from the
falcons
you know in the division they could get
some wins it's just it's not going to be
easy it's not going to be easy and you
mentioned peyton manning
and the 28 interceptions he had as a
rookie
the record which still stands 23 years
later i guarantee you
that he will be mapping out the schedule
week in and week out
hoping that as many of those rookie
quarterbacks are on the field because
now with 17 games
maybe finally someone will break that
record i talked to him about it i think
when blake bortles
had gotten close in 2014
i think it was he clearly he jokes about
his good natured about it he's clearly
bothered
by the fact that he has held that record
for so long and he really would
like someone to do him the honor of
breaking it and with 17 games
there's one more chance for someone to
do it right the dolphins are another
team you've done some work on
and this is a team that fascinates me
because they're
still under the radar screen we still
don't know what to make of them they had
some good games last year
they had some moments they ultimately
didn't make the playoffs so they fell on
the fail
side of the pass fail are you a
successful team line
but they've worked the draft board
masterfully
they keep building and building towards
something
and uh you know they're in a division
that all of a sudden is
pretty damn competitive with the bills
and the patriots and who knows what zack
wilson and the jets are going to be
what's been your impression of the
dolphins based upon their draft
when i look at the dolphins right now
this is the first year
where i've started to think okay they
have
stopped playing just for the future now
they believe right now if tuatanga veloa
is the guy
that they can win right now okay because
if you
look at that trade that they use laramie
tunsil for
you know tentacles of that trade
basically are gonna last till 2023
when san francisco's one is at least
right now the last thing left
from that laramie tunsil trade but if
you look at the way they drafted mike
and everybody said
why would you trade back from 12 to six
to get jalen waddle you could have
stayed at 12 and
had that extra number one next year and
their thought process
i believe is very very simple we are
ready to win now
we are prepared in 2021
to challenge anybody in the nfl and to
win right now
so that's why in my opinion whereas
i think maybe a year or two ago if they
had
traded from 3 to 12
i'm not sure they would have gone back
up to six
and taken a future one and traded it to
get back up to six so they could have
gotten their receiver
they clearly have said right now mike we
believe
jalen waddle to our team right now
is worth two first-round draft choices
and so
that's what that's the difference in
their drafts now they are
picking players now that they believe
can help them win
both now and in the future the last
thing i would say
from that trade from that uh you know
from their future
from their past trades chris greer now
has gotten three new starters
on his offensive line and in my
opinion those three guys really have to
be the building blocks
because they're low salaried guys and
they are guys who they
think are going to take that offense
into the future
along with tuatanga veloa but obviously
none of this really matters if tua can't
play
so this is a really important year for
him obviously
the jets gave sam darnold three years to
declare himself one way or the other as
a franchise quarterback in their
estimation and i think
it helped them decide they were going to
say he's not
because they were in position to get
zach wilson how much time do you think
two is going to get in miami
the the the logical thing to say is that
you saw the way tua got yanked last year
and so clearly if he got yanked that way
last year brian flores
has a good backup in jacoby percent and
he'll do it again this year
i think the one difference is last year
they had ryan fitzpatrick
who uh was this is got one of the
quirkiest careers
in the 101 years of nfl history
that he goes in and he wins that game in
vegas that they have no right to win
you know throwing a pass with somebody
twisting his head like he's in the
exorcist
and so ryan fitzpatrick is just a
different guy
i don't think that brian flores is going
to have as quick
a trigger uh you know to pull
tuatagavaloa
for jacoby brissette just because i
think
they want to give tua an absolutely
full opportunity to win this job
for the next 10 years and i don't think
they think
you do that by yanking them in and out
of the lineup
yeah i agree with you at some point you
got to let him fight through those
moments
one way or the other so he's better
prepared for the next time those moments
come along
and it may be that losing a game like
that once or twice
equips him to start winning games like
that once he understands the emotions
and the flow
and everything that goes into trying to
dig your way out of a hole
that you've created for yourself based
upon the early stages of a game let's
pivot
to the 49ers there's been so much talk
about that
quarterback decision and you know sims
and i said
as they were caught up in this question
of which guy is it going to be
and they seem to be relishing the
attention but also truly undecided
that whenever they did put a name on the
card they were going to try to sell as
best they could the idea that whoever
they take was the guy
all along and they're still trying to
sell that peter
i just don't know how many people are
buying it
well look you know kyle shanahan had a
very uh you know he had a long
explanation for me um two minutes and 37
seconds as to why they picked him that's
that's long in media parlance and you
know the longer that i talk to him
the more i believe him about trey lance
because i think he believes that trey
lance
in in the way that modern quarterbacks
play
that is he as accurate especially as
accurate down
field as mack jones is no he's not
but especially in modern football when
pockets collapse
and you know you have to make some plays
on the run that
trey lance that is his major advantage
over mac jones and i think i believe
uh you know kyle shanahan but mike i'll
also say this
i think kyle shanahan legitimately
struggled
with this decision he told me
uh you know on saturday night
essentially that
there were times when i would look at
the tape and i would say this guy
absolutely is the guy and then the next
day i would say man
what was i thinking i would look at this
play or i would think he only threw the
ball
320 times or whatever in his college
career
at that level of competition and he
would question himself
but i think at the end of the day the
athleticism went over
and he understands that he's not getting
as precise as precise a passer
as he would be getting in mack jones and
i understand what chris sims
says as a quarterback you know you can
make
plays all day from the pocket
you know and he will and i think that
mac jones gonna have a very good nfl
career
and i think he would have been good
really good in san francisco
but i think the athleticism really
convinced
shanahan to go over the the other
direction
yeah i think it's the philosophical
shift away from
the kirk cousins style quarterback who
can
run the play that's called exactly the
way kyle shanahan
wants it to be run every move every
hitch every read every
throw everything he's basically an
extension of kyle shanahan
and now shanahan is embracing the
patrick mahomes off schedule abilities
that when the play that's called goes to
hell
instead of throwing it away taking a
sack
finding some way to just end it and move
on to the next play
you've got a guy who can use his
athleticism
to create something on the fly and that
is so antithetical to the way kyle
shanahan views offense
he views offense as everything is
planned out
and mapped out and if we do it my way
we're going to crack the code of the
defense and we're gonna win the game
the last thing he wants is his
quarterback out there
running around like he's in someone's
backyard
just trying to make something happen and
and i think that was the tension and
that's why
some believe that mac jones was the guy
when they made the move
and that someone or more than one
someone's within the 49ers organization
gently nudged shanahan over a period of
five weeks
toward trade lands you know if they do
the trade the day but
maybe it is mac jones if you are
if if you are well look if they don't
make the trade they would have drafted
mack jones
if they're sitting there you know where
they're where you know where they're
regularly going to draft you know say at
number 12
they would have taken mack jones but i
think
what this got to be about mike
is this perception got out there
that the 49ers were taking mack jones
and honestly that was great for the
49ers
because whether they ended up taking
mack jones or not so the trade is made
on on march 26th
right and right away you know chris sims
who's obviously close to kyle
shanahan uh adam schefter who knows kyle
very well
they both basically said hey you know we
don't know what they're going to do but
we think that you know that that the
49ers are going to take mack jones
and so and some and sometimes got even
stronger than that
the reason i think that was good for the
49ers is that it allowed them
to basically now even inside their own
building
kyle shanahan told me mike that
when he thought that a coach
was talking to him you know his
offensive coordinator quarterback coach
whatever
and thought that well i know you like
trey lance because of this
that he would go back at him and he says
no i like mac jones because of this
and and so he would never even tell he
told me
that he did not tell the coaches on his
staff
until trevor lawrence was picked uh by
the jacksonville jaguars
he said it was that important to us to
keep an absolute lid on it
but why peter i don't get it no one was
gonna jump them for trey lance or mac
jones i think this is the old solution
without a problem being
cute trying to get some attention so you
build a mystery so people tune in for
the draft
i think what it does now it sets up an
apples to apples comparison between trey
lance and mac jones
and if jones ends up being a star with
the patriots
and lance struggles in part because they
stick him on the bench for a year or two
behind jimmy garoppolo
they are going to look like buffoons for
giving up three first-round picks
and a third round pick to get trey lance
what if you're trying to convince the
world that you're going to take mack
jones
what if there's five teams out there
what if what if there's five teams out
there that
have have engaged you to some degree
about jimmy garoppolo and have talked to
you a little bit about trading for
garoppolo
and you have said all along we're not
trading garoppolo
unless you give us a one and so now
if there's a bunch of teams out there
and who knows maybe it's new england
maybe it's four or five other teams
who eventually were going to take a
quarterback in this draft
and who say well if they secretly love
mac jones
the way the 49ers really like mac jones
and they know they're not going to get
them maybe they pay the
49ers a 1 for jimmy garoppolo obviously
that never happened
that's all i can think of mike that is
that it was to their advantage to
convince
teams that they were taking mac jones
because then
some team that wanted mac jones was then
gonna have to engage him on garoppolo
i just think they've been all over the
place and i don't think it's nearly as
strategic as they want us to think i
think they got freaked out by the fact
that they whiffed on mahomes
they got freaked out by the fact that
they said no thank you to a tom brady
homecoming
and both of those guys were in the super
bowl last year and they got
desperate and now they're trying to make
it look like they had a plan all along
and i think the plan was
holy crap what do we do to fix this
situation at quarterback
let's throw three first round picks and
a third round pick onto the pile
and we'll figure out later what it is
that we're gonna do and now they're
still trying to figure out what they're
gonna do with jimmy garoppolo and
they're trying to sell the idea
that he's gonna be the wire to wire
starter in 2021 and i don't buy that
either
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports